all right Gentlemen please stay with us
I want to bring in kellyanne Conway
former senior counselor to president
Trump and Molly Hemingway
editor-in-chief at the Federalist both
Fox News contributors kellyanne um again
we have a secretary of defense who's on
bed rest who was missing or not in touch
or nobody was looking for him for days
so how does the administration at this
point still keep the American public in
the dark with the president you know
calling a lid tonight this see this
seems like I can't imagine this having
happened in the Trump Administration
well when have for several reasons
either president Trump would be
underwing or in the Press briefing room
or calling reporters into the Oval
Office if it were later into the night
maybe he'd be firing off a couple of
tweets that we were told were so chaotic
and so crisis Laden but at least then
you would know what the
commander-in-chief was thinking you
would also have spokespeople from the
Department of Defense look I think that
the Secretary of Defense being absent
all those days should concern everyone
because it they basically proved he's
not a vital part of the conversation
here of the coordination um Laura this
is exactly why whose commander-in-chief
is important and when you when you stop
designating terrorist as terrorist
you're asking them you're inviting them
to be terrorists again and you're
inviting them to threaten America her
interests her people and her values her
Freedom um I think what it what what the
gentleman were just saying is incredibly
important because when people look at
this they say this is not some distant
fight that's not ours people are so
concerned now that what's happening
there is affecting us here and this is
why president Trump long ago pivoted to
a general election strategy against
Biden he wants you to think about their
two presidencies there two
Administration sure economy energy
border but this particularly as he said
last night in Fox News this town hall
first president in 72 years to not start
a new new war we called terrorist
terrorists we brought hostages home um
you look at Iran who funds so much of
what we're talking about in this world
it's so scary when you look at Iran they
were starving to make deals by the time
we left our Administration now they
basically 3 million three million
barrels a day they stockpile over 80
billion you know where it's going you
see on the screen where it's going but
Laura and Molly I think this is why even
in the personal attribute questions
Trump is beating Biden who has a plan
who cares about the middle class who has
the energy and ability who has the
vision and experience but also on all
the major issues security and
affordability um people are very
concerned and they are they're against
Biden I think they're hid and biding do
you know last Point we've heard more
about and from Hunter Biden than Joe
Biden the last two days we've seen more
of Hunter than Joe Biden disgrace well
it was interesting last night one of the
questions that was asked at the Town
Hall was about some concern that people
might have that chaos would return if
Trump were elected and Trump's answer
was pointing out some of the chaos that
we're seeing in the country right now
not just domestically but
internationally and this is a really
serious situation I mean it's a serious
situation that the houis have been
bombing shipping routes and that that
affects so many things something needs
to be done about this but we've also
been in Conflict either in a proxy way
or otherwise with these people for quite
some time now this is the third
Administration and you want to have good
communication with the American people
you also want to do things in a
constitutional Manner and again Biden is
not the first president to violate what
the Constitution says about how Congress
should be involved when launching air
strikes but this is a good example of
why Congress should be involved because
we do need to think about to the point
that what's next yeah well and and also
uh how we're going to deal with this
being involved in a global conflict in
multiple Parts when we're broke yes and
uh it but but it it matters to people
and how we do it matters and it doesn't
seem like a lot of our defense industry
or that our defense leadership have been
thinking about how to effectively win
Wars they're very good about entering
into them we haven't won a war since
World War II right they're very good
about having them go for a long time
eight years what is that but we need to
know more about what their strategy is
before we' let them do yet another one I
think um you know Billy Joel is saying
it's a matter of trust you know who's
trusting what's happening here and
that's why you really do have to have
someone in place you can say okay even
if we disagree with this action they're
laying it out for us peace through
strength that's what president Trump
talked about last night and when you
have a weak economy when you're
self-loathing I talk about this in a
little bit you're teaching people to
hate your country you're supporting the
pro Hamas uh protesters on college
campuses maybe they're going to be
supporting hooes tomorrow I think this
is why um Trump right now is he really
is
re realigning what's the traditional
democratic Coalition of Voters I mean
he's really buing into Hispanics and
African-Americans Independence firsttime
voters who are young or maybe not young
maybe they're just first-time voters
Laura but the other the other thing here
is that we made it the party of the
worker we made it the it was
Administration that was there for the
work and when you look at when you even
talk to Iowa's caucus goers they're
mentioning things like this they're not
just just talking about inflation
they're not just talking about the the
cost of gr gas and groceries and the
Border crisis they're talking about
what's going on all around the world the
hot spots and we were told crisis in a
tweet chaos and Palace Intrigue there's
crisis and Chaos everywhere we look
everywhere look H back once again but
remember the the adults will now be in
charge see what's happen there but you
know we do have a real different Vision
here of foreign policy and I think we
were robbed of that in the 2020 election
to have an actual debate about whose
foreign policy was better it was kind of
a Ed by corporate media that Biden had a
better foreign policy and we now have
this unique situation where we can just
compare compare the four years under the
Trump Administration with the four years
under Biden and see who had the just
objectively speaking a far better record
does that not speak to the fact that the
US media has so fallen down on its job
to First vet Joe Biden in 2020 he was
not up to the job everybody knew it and
they hid it for him he was a hologram
candidate and he's a hologram president
who calls a lid on a night like tonight
this is a failure across the board of
the elites The Establishment and the
corporate media Molly you hit this every
day they have a lot to be accountable
here tonight yeah and they're very much
responsible for getting us into the
situation by failing to vet and it's why
it's so important that people are able
to have a good evaluation of of what
they're getting into there's one reason
and the name is Trump everything flows
from Trump if you challenge anyone to
answer a question about Joe Biden is our
commander-in chief our farm policy or
the or this secretary defense being
missing and you ask them to answer the
question Laura mly they can't go 10
words or 10 seconds without saying Trump
five times they're they're so obsessed
with him and so the Trump Arrangement
syndrome is real there's no vaccine no
therapeutic for it and uh it's so real
that it was okay not to vet him it's
okay to lie it's okay to pretend that
what you see Joe Biden and KLA Harris
not up to the task while we are at war
in so many places including at our
Southern border that's okay because the
alternative is Trump it's outrageous I
actually think that's part of the reason
why they have such hatred toward Trump
you remember in 2016 they said if he
were elected we would have nuclear
conflict we would have conflict all over
the world he wouldn't be up to handling
the task of all these Global issues in
play and then when he not only won which
surprised so many people but then did
such an effective job and you see even
again with the with the town hall last
night where he had you know pretty
effective responses to these questions
that were being asked I actually think
that's part of the reason why people
hate him so much is that they resent
that he has command and control and is
funny is you know and is engaging with
people this was all over the Internet 12
hours ago that this was going to take
place president Trump was dining with
President XI of China at
marago and I was between the main course
and dessert you know we unleash a
missile attack against one of our
adversaries uh nobody knew about it
Syria yeah yeah remember I remember it
very well he said didn't have a 12-h
hour notice that this was going to
happen he said that crazy person gassed
kids and here's my response um and well
but but isn't that funny too we were
told we were the leakers nobody even
knew things like that were happening as
they were happening and what does
President Trump he even said it last
night in the Fox News Town Hall he said
they broadcast everything or he said it
in an interview recently they broadcast
everything you don't tell your enemies
what you're going to do before you do it
they're your enemies for a reason they
don't we don't have this kind of
discipline we don't have this kind of
coordination and collaboration right now
because Joe Biden and KLA Harris has a
number one and number two in our
nation's government um make otherwise
smart people say really stupid things
all the time we have a cabinet of
firsts and then we have Tony blink who
started his tenure as Secretary of State
essentially getting lectured by China
remember that meeting in Alaska and now
headline in the New York Times blinkin
talks a Grand Vision from m east peace
but hits a wall in Israel strikes expand
Battleground for the West for the war in
the middle least I mean it's not
surprising there's been a very muddled
Vision there there have been mixed
messages about what what our role is
with with Israel and um and it's not
surprising all right ladies hold on hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else